elle allait d'un sos lancés depuis kiev
volodymyr zelensky s'est adressé une
nouvelle fois au congrès américain il
demande à joe biden de prendre ses
responsabilités et cela passe par la
création d'une zone d'exclusion aérienne
en d'autres termes l'interdiction de
tout vol au dessus de l'ukraine écoutez
nous devons protéger le ciel ukrainien
pour protéger les citoyens et ainsi la
russie ne pourra pas continuer à
terroriser nos villes libres si c'est
trop demander eh bien nous proposons une
alternative
vous savez de quel système de défense
aérienne nous avons besoin
nous
nous avons besoin d'une aviation
puissante pour protéger notre peuple
notre terre notre liberté
ainsi vous pourrez aider les ukrainiens
vous pourrez aider l'europe
cela devrait dit on vous retrouve en
direct de washington
on connaît la réponse de joe biden qui
doit s'exprimer dans la journée
concernant ce donc cette demande de deux
hélène ce qu'il n'y aura pas de no fly
zone
oui joe biden doit s'exprimer d'ici peu
et en effet il ne faut pas s'attendre à
un changement fondamental de la
politique de l'administration byden qui
veut éviter de prendre des mesures qui
pourraient être perçu par moscou comme
une escalade on compte 100 la maison
blanche marche vraiment sur un fils joe
biden l'a dit répété il ne veux pas
entraîner les états unis dans une
troisième guerre mondiale donc il n'y
aura pas d'avion américain ou de troupes
américaines en ukraine joe biden qui
devrait annoncer dans son discours
aujourd'hui par contre une aide
militaire supplémentaire de 800 millions
de dollars d'aidé militaire donc à
l'ukraine mais c'est vrai que plus
les images des civils ukrainien pris
sous les bombes de moscou et bien sont
surtout nos écrans plus la position de
washington devient inconfortable
d'ailleurs le président hélène ce qui a
interpellé directement aujourd'hui le
président byden il a notamment déclaré
vous êtes le leader d'une grande nation
je souhaite que vous soyez le leader du
monde et être le leader du monde c'est
d'être le leader de la paix volodymyr
zelensky sonia qui essayent de
convaincre les américains ils tentent de
les toucher en plein coeur en convoquant
notamment pearl harbor et même le 11
septembre 2001
oui c'est vrai que le président zelensky
a profité de l'admiration qu'il suscite
auprès des élus américains d'ailleurs il
a été accueilli avec une
standing-ovation pour demander plus des
deux aux états unis et pour cela et bien
il a tout de suite et bien interpeller
les a mêlés les élus en dressant un
parallèle entre les bombardements
aériens de monstres moscou et les
attentats du 11 septembre aux états unis
ou encore l' attaque de l'aviation
japonaise sur la base américaine de
pearl harbor il a notamment déclaré
souvenez-vous de pearl harbor quand
votre ciel a été assombrie par les
avions qui vous attaquer il a ensuite de
façon plutôt habile à renouveler sa
demande pour une zone d'exclusion
aérienne puisque là encore il a pris une
référence américaine le discours de
martin luther king junior il a dit haye
rave dream g1 rêve à l'avenir j'ai un
besoin j'ai besoin que vous fermiez le
ciel ukrainien et là on a senti quand
même une grande émotion au congrès
américain le congrès américain qui
depuis le début de l'invasion russe en
ukraine a été un relais influents pour
kiev à relais donc auprès de la maison
blanche d'ailleurs de nombreux élus ont
déjà exhorté le président biden a
facilité par exemple la livraison
d'avions au polonais mig-29 à l'ukraine
donc le président ukrainien comptait
vraiment sur ce congrès américain pour
qu'il relaie ses demandes auprès du
président bayonne merci beaucoup sonné